in 1996 a team of scientists led by
David McKay announced that they had
discovered evidence of fossilized
bacteria in a martian meteorite the
meteorite originated from Mars traveled
around the solar system for perhaps
millions of years and impacted
Antarctica the discovery of fossilized
life on a martian meteorite would have
been the first definitive proof of life
beyond our Earth it made headlines
around the world it was even announced
on the White House lawn by Bill Clinton
Rock
841 speaks to us across all those
millions of miles it speaks of the
possib ility of life however in the year
2000 a new study found that the
structures that were thought to be
fossilized bacteria were actually just
inorganic minerals the original study
was retracted from the retraction of the
claim of evidence for Martian life we
can learn many things scientific
research is a process of refinement and
iteration it is important to be open to
new evidence and to be willing to change
one's conclusions life may be out there
and we still should search with all our
mind to find it but until we have
definitive confirmation we just don't
know